[Music]
okay
this fall
six cities
prepare
[Applause]
for two
rebels with a cause
[Applause]
[Music]
phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york baltimore
[Applause]
the rebels with a cars comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
hmm
i always realized too when i do that sip
i forget how to breathe properly
do i sip first do i breathe first you
would think that something as basic as
breathing is something one would
it should be on autopilot
apparently i need a checklist actually
uh all right we have so much to get you
today but yes uh we told you about it
you were asking about it tickets are on
sale now at
louderworthcrowder.com tour the fall
tour with both dave and i and these are
uh some big ass venues because we've had
to do two three shows everywhere else so
you can meet your fellow uh viewers of
the show we are going to be in phoenix
ahoy houston ahoy charleston west
virginia ahoy nashville ahoy new york
city ahoy and baltimore high
yup technically it's red bank new jersey
because new york city didn't want us but
uh you know it's it's basically new york
city it's like that's so close 20
minutes out of there it's just cleaner
yes
and if you stand on the right street
corner you will find yourself you'll
catch yourself a cory booker that's true
or kevin smith or kevin smith no no no
kevin's kevin smith is straight uh so he
is the quickest wit in the west he's
here you know when you love him dave
landau how are you oh good how about you
i am all right we have we have so many
stories to get to today and none of it
is the stock market because you've
probably looked at your portfolio gerald
a my best man the better man how are you
i was doing well until i just looked
down and saw that it's down again yeah
now so you know i'm gonna hang my nose
yeah my fidelity app just deleted itself
guys
well why don't you cry about it my uh my
robin hood app just stole it
my acorn ass celestia gosh i got so much
money in celsius hmm yeah that's a
mistake crypto the great thing is no one
can control it except for the person who
decided to control it exactly except for
the person who runs the company you
invested in
who owns all of it right and can't cash
it out oh my gosh if i have one more
person who actually puts your hardware
in crypto just shut up whatever okay
i've had crypto for a long i understand
it but stop acting like it's the new
it's the new gold mining
no
zip it
all right
a fun sketch an old prospector you're
trying to i got it
bitcoin
look at all this but uconn i thought you
wanted
ethereum nothing
because there's no hard goods yes
there's coin up in them hills
servers um servers so we'll be talking
today about uh quite a few things so
first off there's stuff happening with
saudi arabia i don't know if you know
this we can't produce oil here in the
united states but we'll beg saudi arabia
for at the same time while uh you know
disney panders to hopefully get saudi
arabia as one of their markets we'll be
talking about lizzo
so um big conversation yeah have your
have your splash guards ready
and uh we'll be talking about uh as well
i'm trying to think of what else are we
oh ohio teachers are allowed to carry
firearms now they are they were before
but it was ridiculous you had to
basically have 20 years of police
officer training or something or 700 or
700 hours so it's a good thing cnn lied
about it this morning we'll fact check
them and then if you uh are watching of
course on mug club we're going to
address that trans story uh the
propaganda piece on fox news and i know
it was last friday but i don't think
anyone's done a really good job of
rebutting it so my question to you first
is it's pride month and here's cultural
appropriation month uh this this
thursday taiwan by the way yeah so we
celebrate prime month by not celebrating
pride month but let me ask you a
question is what do you think it's going
to take
to stop the lgbt the the pandering
with children now i mean remember that
they weren't coming for your kids
anyway those are the days yeah i just
bought crayons for my son they were a
rainbow of colors yes that's the problem
they're going at them they're going at
them everywhere
and you're like this black's not a color
it's a shade what is this huh you always
have that one kid in grade school which
black and white are not colors they're
shades you got me jeez go eat your
crayons also they shouldn't put white in
the box no they really shouldn't i mean
for a lot of reasons it's just
encouraging them to ruin your black
leather couch exactly
um and you can do with it besides
ruining a leather couch there's nothing
else you can do no there isn't you can't
color with it i mean unless you know you
go to your teenage brother's room and
ruin his black walls because he bought
paint at hot topic now
you know how you know how people would
get really upset when we used to imply
or you used to believe wrongfully so
wrongfully so wrong false notion that
the lgbtq aip community is the most
decadent hyper-sexualized
community in the world well um
here's christina aguilera who just and
if you have kids by the way this is not
a trigger warning they just they
shouldn't see this we've blurred it but
they would market this to kids i'm
telling you kids shouldn't be watching
this here's christina aguilera at uh los
angeles pride event
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
even with the blur you can still change
pretty visible jeez she's a mother yeah
father
[ __ ]
yeah well the blur is 12 inches yeah
it's very generous blur by the way the
event was open to all ages what all ages
and here's the thing when they go well
you know what uh you know straight
people get divorces and they'll have to
make the argument about gay marriage you
know what straight people have
pornography you know what no straight
people are saying that guar concerts
should be open to all ages
well and every time that i see like demi
lovato or one of those dancers or
singers i'm just like this this is
you're you're not talented you're just a
[ __ ] going out there showing your butt
to an audience well christina aguilera
is uh is talented she's also a 50 year
old [ __ ] uh well she just stayed that
way and just to be clear talented yeah
just to be clear
i mean she does too much running you
know what they're like hey
i was like hold the note yeah that yeah
yeah yeah yeah
gonna rub her the right way it doesn't
appear there's the wrong way christina
take a note from celine dion or
carpenter
you're not cool yeah well neither are
you with a 12-inch penis okay i don't
think that's very cool but what do i
know call me mr old fashioned this is
one of those situations where uh when i
say [ __ ] just to be clear what do i
mean i mean selling sex for money yeah
well there you go clear
on the same page yeah would you prefer
prostitute i'm willing to uh amend the
statement
is there anything else we need to say
about that i mean look this is remember
they would say we'd say look hold on a
second we just don't want you
hypersexualizing our community with
children oh why do you think that we're
gonna do that
because you were on stage with a 12-inch
rubber [ __ ] open to all ages i don't
know i just uh
i don't are we missing each other
yeah i mean the personification of a man
is a 12-inch strap-on yes that's the
standard yes absolutely i don't know
she's wearing the chest plate too right
and another girl coming over and things
saying sex xxxxxxx is what they were
saying right so i mean it's it's
obviously family friendly when we were
kids think of how scandalous it was just
salt salt and pepper yeah with no r oh i
love saltwater push it push it good
you're like
no here we are
yes i love the i love them though and
the condiments can you imagine making
this argument in 1999 it's really like
because in 2022 christina aguilera will
have a 12-inch penis on and everybody's
going to think that that is totally fine
you when you're fear-mongering with the
slippery slope yeah now i'm serious
you'll see it huge girl not fine yeah
yeah who who sings genie in a bottle the
song your girlfriend puts on why would
she need to do that she's cute
okay fine a man will be walking down the
street and a parade having breasts and
twerking with a police officer how about
that never seen that at a christmas
parade you never saw santa claus show
you his penis no santa misses never seen
saint patty's irish meat and potatoes no
closed doors
lord knows i have at least he looked
like santa i said man with breasts and
woman with dil i just okay yeah well you
know it should have been enough it just
boy it's just it's it's just too you
would be dying laughing if you were a
kid that's the truth like if i was like
seven or eight years old in the crowd as
a kid yeah i would be crying laughing
and it's not that's
not something you should say no also i'd
grow up never feeling like a real man
because i was a very generous rubber
apparatus well yeah how are you ever
going to live up to that
you're never going to live up to the
size of christina aguilera's penis
that's true
disney star 2 12 inch dung speaking of
size and trust me we'll get to more
serious news in a second but you know
what this does matter because this is
how they this is how they open the door
to then have drag queen story hour for
your kids to then market to your
children and then say that children
should transition and then we get to the
point where parents are disallowed from
not permitting transition of their
children right now you have child
protective services that's how you go
down the steps let's be really clear
about it
it does start with the the absolving of
all any and all moral standards and look
i'm gonna i don't care you guys want to
do that at a show with adults fine but
deliberately making it open to all
children it's the same thing you want to
do your drag queen story hour no one
complained just to be clear no one
complained when you did it at your
private gay bars no but when you do it
at a public library with children all of
a sudden that's where you get people i
guess guilty of hate speech and by that
i mean criticizing your 12-inch rubber
penis
now
speaking of unsightly bookmark yeah
it doesn't really work that well
tomorrow kids
when you have a pop-out book
[Laughter]
it ruins all the pop-ups yes
uh speaking of talentless and unsightly
lizzo um just changed the lyrics to her
new song girls with no eye
gur that's how you know your hip is when
you don't use vowels
or like a bear yes exactly right like or
like the sound that no man ever makes
when they see
lisa that would be called
[Laughter]
so she changed the lyrics to her song
girls after being confronted online and
so she walked it back about and not for
the reasons you think
a problematic slur in the song
lizzo is listening and taking action
following backlash to the lyrics of her
new song girls the three time grammy
winner responds to the criticism on
instagram after being called out for
including a word that's considered to be
an ableist slur she adds i'm proud to
say there's a new version of girls with
a lyric change as an influential artist
i'm dedicated to being part of the
change i've been waiting to see in the
world now here's what's so funny about
that trigger warning for all of you who
think that you're adults but aren't they
try and avoid the slur so you're sitting
like oh my gosh what was it was it the n
word maybe it was a c word maybe it was
the b word no no she says that stuff all
the time
the word
was spazz
oh sorry what yes the word was spazz and
i love it like this is what happens is
when everyone just agrees oh it's not he
it's it's she oh you can't say we can't
say spaz you know like gypped we lost
egypt
we should never lose that because of the
gypsies and their traveling caravans
like come on what am i offending the
broad from hunchback of notre dame now
the term is allegedly derogatory uh
because it's an ableist slur that's how
it's labeled in uk and australia what so
fam
what if someone's a spaz yeah you can't
say that we all know somebody who's like
way too hyper dave you're gonna get us
banned i'm sorry i didn't mean to defend
the hype let's not throw around the s
word like that
can we say [ __ ]
oh you son of a bro
i mean that's the full word you just did
it with a hard seed yes
what did doctors do when they prescribe
the anti-spasmodal
just uh you know what you know what just
take the opioids i don't even want to
say this
take the bottle yes don't call me right
92 and don't call me in the morning yes
just fill a hot tub yeah
disconnect your phone have you seen
killing versace you've seen that the
last scene with ricky martin you know
do that yeah
now um fans did reach out to her because
spazz is a slur now and uh these are
some tweets of them voicing the
disappointment please remove the word
and they dash it out by the way they
dash it out
today at the uh today show whatever
their website is please remove the word
s dash dash z spazz just for those
listening on audio just to i'm clear
they're still using the same word uh
please remove the word spazz from your
new song because it's a slur and really
offensive to the disabled community the
slur stems from medical terminology that
was hijacked and then used to mock
people then there was the noted
disability advocate hannah
divani devine i don't know how it's
pronounced
she tweeted out my disability cerebral
palsy is literally classified as [ __ ]
dipl diplegia diplegia
your new song makes me pretty angry plus
sad uh and even where she followed it up
with a tweet that read
them
so that happens
we're not gonna be issuing any
retractions or this isn't the today show
we tried to space it out but you
wouldn't have understood it okay bro and
lizzo immediately uh caved uh into
herself like a dying star
pointing out a statement it's clearly
what she did it's clearly not what she
meant
yeah that's what it was about cerebral
palsy yeah she was saying like i hate
them shaky mother yeah what do you call
that thing they got i want to rap battle
them in the all up in the wee chair
talking to robot [ __ ]
cause that's what i think of when i
think of as a spaz yes a person who's
disabled exactly yeah it's the opposite
of that it's really a hyper person who
won't calm down right that's what i
thought
so liz
she put out a statement saying it's been
brought to my attention that there is a
harmful word in my new song girls no i i
feel dumber just having read it i never
want to promote a derogatory language as
a fat black woman in america well at
least you own it i've had many hurtful
words used against me so i over stand
the power of words did she actually
write over stand yes she did this was
copy and paste
look no she mashed so much yeah
so much money
like potatoes her touchpad is like those
old people telephone numbers oh i can't
imagine we have voice recognition now
all you have to do is say it
she probably did well yeah it's better
than just the number five
so i overstand
i do not understand i overstand
sometimes i through stan [ __ ] that's
understanding too much
i overstand the power words can have as
an influential artist i'm dedicating to
being part of the change i've been
waiting to see
in the world now here's the thing
there are many things
heavy thing
i am
michael jackson's man in the mirror for
her it's the woman in two minutes
a giant mirror
i bought a fun house missiles
it don't matter if you're ten or nine
stone
which probably was a stupid that's a
stupid measuring when they in the uk
like yeah i'm nine stone well what's
that uh i don't know 10 stone is a 40
pound difference because it doesn't seem
accurate that's an odd oh jeez it's not
measurement so here's the thing she
apologized for something that i couldn't
care less about but again this you're
watching this happen in real time
remember how you all thought like when
did we lose the word [ __ ] i didn't
even know we lost that word and we lost
it the word spaz now you're going to
have your children said you can't say
the s word and this isn't because it's
something that everybody agreed upon
that it's something that was
deliberately designed to be offensive
let's not compare this to something like
the n-word which was deliberately used
right to subjugate people which was
deliberately used it was created to be
derogatory let's be clear about the
difference of the historical context of
like the n-word in the united states
versus
spaz it didn't mean this it wasn't
intended to be ableist but people decide
that they are going to remove words
remember lenny bruce don't take my words
away now it's let's take all of the
words away that's a problem and you're
seeing it in real time i know you think
spaz maybe doesn't really matter because
you don't use the word that much it's
going to be another word and it's going
to be another word and they'll always
compare it to civil rights they'll
always come just like with gay marriage
they would say well are you against
interracial marriage hold on a second i
don't believe that someone who's born
with a different shade of skin uh and
has been actually the subject of of
oppression of of torture of wrongful
treatment of actually foregoing their
civil rights i don't think that should
all be compared to your preference of
friction that's just my personal belief
in the same thing now they want to
compare spazz to
slurs racial slurs
oh i just remember writing all my
favorite bands when i was a boy about
what offended me yes and i liked that
they changed all the words back then
right yeah yeah alice cooper got right
on that yeah he was right
jeremy was originally called dan yes
yeah and kiss was originally called i
mean it was a sexual thing oh they
scaled it back love fun became love god
yep
i just don't if you actually can't even
say gun anymore happiness is a warm rope
but if you actually the problem is this
is being given into yes like you're so
entitled that you actually wrote a pop
star that you were offended by a word
yeah and she changed it that's insane
you wrote a pop planet who misspells the
word girls and consistently creates the
most profane disgusting lyrics
and
accompanying visuals uh because of what
offends you so by the way no apology for
these other links and i don't think she
should have to apologize for the elite
these look just to be clear yeah or the
other one and i haven't heard the song i
deliberately avoided it but these are
the this is the song this is how it
begins
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] uh-huh hold my bag
[ __ ] hold my bag do you see this [ __ ]
hold me back i'm about to knock somebody
out yo we're my best friend she the only
one i know to talk me off the deep end
all right
that's pretty good graphic imagery i'mma
go lorena bobbitt on him so he never f
again no oh no you never f again bro
pizza pizza so you're mad about spazz
where she is threatening to cut off a
man's penis
yes so he can never
procreate again that's a hate crime it's
anti-trans
yeah i mean it well it depends on the
day i guess if you're not choosing to be
with christina aguilera it's auntie
polymer that's true
the phrase spazz is the problem yeah i
should have been a lyricist yes just
read [ __ ] four times on a piece of
paper there's a new song i'm a poet yes
who couldn't forget robert frost talking
about lorena bobbitting your [ __ ] so
that you never f again bro emily
dickinson who just i remember that as
she stared out to the fields of uh
[ __ ] be crazy
edgar allen hoe yes
people are so self-important and so i
mean we have remember when christopher
pine tweeted out i think it was
guardians of the galaxy why did you say
christopher is it chris pine yeah oh
sorry i've never once said christopher
christopher though were you thinking of
robin no no the guy that started you're
thinking of christopher robin
it's fine okay fine all right remember
when he tweeted out turn it up when
guardians of the galaxy two came out
because the soundtrack was great or one
whichever one it was and right deaf
community like just went after him and
he had to sign an apology
i was like
why have you given an inch like people
listen i get it if you don't like it
fine don't listen to lizzo's songs
they're not good anyway perfect problem
solved if you think she's being i guess
you know slur using slurs against you
she's being insensitive to whatever but
ever since ever since we told people
that you can have an opinion that cannot
be
there's no objection that can be placed
against it you are protected they think
they have a right to do this and that
lizzo has to respond well christopher
pine as you so put it got in trouble for
turn it up wait till i hear pump it up
pump it mediocre pump it down
but why it's not his full you're deaf
right
sorry for deaf people but yeah you know
and the limb different thing that we had
oh that we covered years ago yeah
witches with uh yes and anne hathaway
she's i am so sorry i'm sorry no you're
not nobody no for what that your mom
drank when she was pregnant
what are we gonna do next ban hulk hands
yeah i don't understand yeah but here's
the thing too look remember these are
the same people who attacked and
christian conservatives were saying you
know what we just think that kids
shouldn't have access to this for
example i actually sat in on a speech
from uh matt uh matt stone and he was
talking about he said actually
christians didn't want to ban south park
they just didn't want us to be on early
in the day and we agreed with them yeah
i remember him then saying but then when
we decided we mocked
jesus repeatedly we mock christians
repeatedly and rightfully so he said we
were an equal opportunity offender when
we did it with islam all of a sudden
comedy central wouldn't produce it they
wouldn't allow us to create this program
this is the issue these people who said
that you were hateful for having
standards saying if you don't like it
change the channel now are telling
people that you can't use the word spazz
that you can't say a biological man is a
man these were the same people who
thought that you were
just a prude if you thought that people
actually having sex on stage and on
floats shouldn't be in front of children
so it's not the issue of double
standards it's the issue of entirely
artificially creative standards you were
blamed for having standards at all for
decades you were seen as a square the
left is just a square only it's made up
it's not based on any kind of a thread
of common decency can we all agree can
we all i think most people would agree
you know all right
a man with breast implants fornicating
on floats and christina aguilera is a
pop star with a giant rubber [ __ ] that's
probably not for children
but they go no no no problem with that
that's open to all ages but we're
literally going to have to bleep out the
word spazz in our articles
who are the puritans here
all right
wow that's a good point though
uh i really can't
it's frightening when you break it down
so don't feel guilty for having
standards because the left has them too
they just have the wrong ones and
they're ever changing just gender
blindness and oh gender blindness and i
don't are we supposed to are we supposed
to be disability blind
well i just it's it's a word
it doesn't even mean what you think no
it doesn't even
it's violent statement nobody looks at a
[ __ ]
if somebody is a [ __ ] issue where
they're they're shaking or like you know
nobody's like you're a spaz yeah there
was no down stupid body there was no
root like stephen hawking tied to a tree
like oh no stop come on say your slave
name watch please stop liz is also
health blind uh brendan just sent this
to me i think soon she will be blind the
diabetes no for sure
so this picture she put out the caption
says i'm releasing the idea that i'm
eating good or bad i'm just eating well
she's also releasing the idea that she
uses grammar good there's pineapple on
that pizza well she's getting her daily
intake of fruit it's basically juice i
ate juice for dinner
i got fruits
well it's better than michael moore
right now look let me just be really
clear people are saying are you picking
on lizzo because she's morbidly obese
nope yes
it's now not because she's but because
she's advocating that your children be
now they want to make sure that your
children by the way get called into the
principal's office if they say hey eric
stop being a spaz but lizzo can tell
your children to eat whatever they want
and all body types are the same they're
equal as it really relates to health one
is a lie one is a verifiable lie the
other is just a term that some people
find offensive which isn't meant to be
offensive like we really are in clown
world we really are in fat disgusting
clown world that spazz is eating
everybody's lunch what did you just say
no it's like his eighth bag he's just
stealing them that lizzo is eating
everybody's lunch oh my gosh could you
imagine if she was a spaz she had the
shakes for crying out loud people in
japan would be running from the coasts
is nerd going to be the next problem
but oh i l
nerds i want some nerds i put some nerds
on my pizza and they're like you
did you say candy i happen to have a
disorder yes where i have to wear very
thick glasses taped in the middle
it's just
like miss lizzo look i know that you
think all bodies are healthy but you
need to lose you need to lose uh you
know about 200 pounds or you're gonna
you're gonna lose your foot
how much a foot sway
does that count towards the goal of 200
pounds may i eat it it's just biggest
loser only it's now an amputee just
waddling i win [ __ ] as somebody who
is also limb different now
based on my choices more limbless limb
list should have eaten more pineapple
now that one leg would just like all
right you can stand up and just the bone
rips them
you can't just put all that on one leg
there's no way are you kidding me
all right uh let's get to this too again
what we're talking about double
standards and it's not the hypocrisy of
always it's not double standards because
if there were no double standards you
know the left would have none it's not
the hypocrisy it's that they don't
believe what they tell you
this is the issue it's not that nancy
pelosi had a double standard that she
was hypocritical with covet it's that
she wasn't afraid of coveted when she
was going into a particle vortex to get
her blowout the same thing with aoc the
same thing with whitmer so i want to be
clear it's not just saying well you're
hypocritical we're all hypocrites
everyone here's a hypocrite i understand
that but you can be a hypocrite and
still believe in what you say and fall
short of your standards the left does
not believe what they say so buzz
lightyear that new the new film has the
gay kiss as you is required in a
children's film well disney of course so
now there have been several countries in
the middle east including saudi arabia
who've banned the release of that film
light year surprise due to the inclusion
of a same-sex kiss
pixar's light year has been banned in
the middle east over a same-sex kiss
scene featured in the toy story prequel
spin-off the hollywood reporter has
learned that the film is banned in
various middle east countries including
saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates the scene in question involving
the female character hawthorne voiced by
uzo aduba and her partner was originally
cut from the film but reinstated
following the uproar surrounding a
statement from pixar employees claiming
that disney had been censoring overtly
gay affection and disney ceo bob
chapeck's handling of florida's don't
say gay bill the uae's media regulatory
office announced june 13 that the movie
due for release june 16th was not
licensed for public screening due to its
quote violation of the country's media
content standards okay a couple things
first off who'd have thought the country
that doesn't allow women to drive by
themselves might have a problem with
queer kissing in children's movies and
then think of that statement the
employees at pixar said that disney was
quote editing overtly same-sex
you said overtly we didn't
yes yes you should also you should also
probably think of eliminating overtly
sexual themes for any children's films
be a good place to start yeah i don't
like an unnecessary sex scene in any
movie i don't like that they go to a
place that doesn't have any impact on
the story and i guarantee you this gay
kiss doesn't impact the story and
shouldn't be in a kid's movie anyway i
mean unless it like sets it in place
like a butterfly effect where the
universe just
is destroyed well it shouldn't have that
gay kiss
they did cut
[Laughter]
so now let's bring money and again this
goes back to the idea of standards let's
see what chris evans has to say you know
light year star now so this is what he's
saying now you have that tim then now
and then or no
uh no okay all right so here's what he's
saying now about this and keep in mind
that the middle east is not a huge
market for disney it's not like china um
and also chris evans is there because
why tim allen
was too offensive because keep in mind
tim allen endorsed john kasich
he's the one i knew that he existed but
now you know john kasich's fan was tim
allen so this is not a maga ultra right
as the left wants to label them you know
conservative tim allen was slightly more
conservative you won't find anything
wildly offensive from tim allen you'll
just find him leaning more toward the
right and so he was removed and chris
evans was put in but now you can never
please because appeasing crocodiles is
is futile um chris evans had some words
to say about the middle east and this is
what he said this is how soft it is it's
great that we are part of something
that's making steps forward in the
social inclusion capacity but it's
frustrating that there are still places
that aren't where they should be
so no condemnation of islam or saudi
arabia at all no condemnation of the
ideology that would have a problem with
homosexuality and by the way it's a they
have the right to have this problem you
know what sometimes i look at and say
isis wasn't all wrong now
that's crazy right yeah and by the way
in saudi arabia in other words it
doesn't match the intensity when in
saudi arabia if you're gay
there's the death penalty you can be
flawed who knows if you're you're gonna
be thrown off a rooftop the point is the
condemnation isn't it's frustrating
it's frustrating that christians are
being burned alive in cages i know it
didn't happen in saudi arabia i'm just
saying if the outrage matched the
intensity of the offense if you actually
wanted to look at islam but you don't
because they you know the most extreme
of their ilk blow stuff up so he's had
no trouble though when you look at the
intensity in ripping into republican
leaders who are obviously more hateful
than advocating the death penalty for
homosexuals to lindsey graham chris
evans said hey smithers remember when
you said this you know how you make
america great again tell donald trump to
go to hell
what do they have on you i can't tell if
this shameful 180 is born of fear thirst
either way we will always remember you
as nothing more than a remora here he is
to republicans wow hey republicans are
you listening to this come to life
toilet spew complete lies about the
integrity of our democratic process hey
hold on a second that sounds a little
bit more passionate than it's kind of
frustrating that in saudi arabia they uh
murder anyone with a lisp well
technically it's a flying test right so
if you fly you're not gay but if you
don't then obviously you were gay right
yeah in saudi arabia was just a straight
who got his pilot's license yeah yeah
and unlike you know saudi arabia they're
not all you know closeted republicans
right
[Laughter]
it's just amazing there's a lot though
in the arab countries because i know
that from even being you know of course
because my friends were working like
harmony house and you know uh sam goody
and they'd come in and be like uh yes i
have a special author
right and it was just stacks of gay porn
yes yeah what about uh what about his
condemnation of china we have that too
right right it's gonna make changes he's
condemning the the fact that they're
putting wiegers in camps yeah so he
doesn't stand up for muslims in china
because they can't because that's a
significant market he won't condemn
muslims in the country that by the way
they kill gays and not to mention their
mistreatment of women but he will
condemn christian white conservatives
for saying hey maybe we should have a
wall on our border he got he just went
into a tirade i can't believe this
racism hold on a second you're more
offended by a wall yeah and by the way
we're not throwing gays into it right
exactly where was he when hillary
clinton was saying that the election was
stolen from her in 2016. right was he
also saying can you believe that this
person is challenging the legitimacy of
our elections and undermining our
democracy it's outrage currency he
doesn't believe what he's saying or
certainly he doesn't have you know what
he doesn't have the balls that christina
aguilera has to actually stand up for
what it is that he's saying she does
have bigger balls when faced with actual
adversity of thought so by the way
speaking of saudi arabia uh former vice
president joe biden is going to be
visiting the i use the term kingdom i
use it
i use it ironically
uh
because it's not uh
he's going to be visiting the kingdom
next month to beg for oil
now keep in mind that saudi arabia again
the place that kills gay people
the place that you know doesn't have
equal rights for women and they always
try and trot this out like well we have
plenty of female representatives in
there okay sure can they drive
so um they also kill reporters that are
critical of uh yeah so
well yeah but that's not as bad as
donald trump saying that uh you know
fake news yeah which made you want to
bet that chris evans is like i'm
fiscally conservative but so rightly
liberal i guarantee you yes i'm fiscally
liberal but uh fiscally conservative but
otherwise a prick yeah that's what i do
in other words i like to keep all my
money yes yeah i guarantee you if
hollywood hated democrats i would too
yeah i
i just like cash and i'll say whatever
right yeah so saudi arabia of course is
one of the biggest exporters of crude
oil um it doesn't need to be so hey
leftists
just ins what we're talking about the
green new deal and environment how about
just this how about we should use our
own oil reserves we would never have to
import oil ever again if we actually
tapped everything that we had here in
the united states how about just because
you don't want to support nations not
only that don't have necessarily epa
standards
that murder gays how about that
isn't it wouldn't it be better for us to
i know let's even take an extreme
example hey wouldn't it be better to get
oil even from west virginia around all
those crazy conservative rednecks
wouldn't you still rather get oil from
there than the place that forces gays to
be professional crash test dummies in
saudi arabia wouldn't she just i'm just
saying i mean let's take the most
extreme area of the right here in this
country not even are they advocating for
the execution of all gays by the way
without an actual judicial system
so during his campaign though back then
former vice president joe biden made a
promise to uh
render saudi arabia effectively a pariah
he said we're going to in fact make them
pay the price and make them in fact the
pariah that they are there's very little
social redeeming value in the present
government in saudi arabia now he's
calling them an important partner saying
the united states must engage
to advance its interests including
trying to bring stability and peace to
the middle east
do you think after that first quote
they're like uh sir that's where we get
all our oil oh no
they're a strategic partner like i said
tell we're friends yeah
guys i was kidding i was kidding oh tom
i like the the thing they wear on their
head yeah it's neat
i saw lawrence of arabia yeah i love it
i don't think women should drive is that
silk and this is a woman i shouldn't
drive
and here's the issue is
when do you ever stand the only stand up
for your morals the left when you're
standing up against someone who's not
going to fight back and unfortunately
that is republicans that is
conservatives but i also mean that
they're just they're not actually
calling for execution for all this all
of this misinformation or all of this
grandstanding that donald trump was a
fascist and his supporters want us
typically fascists don't want you to
have more access to guns and lower your
taxes just to be clear they're not
typically ardent defenders of the first
amendment just to be clear but okay
let's even go with that if you were
upset about it
how about places like saudi arabia
former vice president joe biden
disney is just allowing chris evans to
sort of you know issue this milk toast
response because
they don't make any money in the middle
east so like all right we'll allow just
say you're frustrated don't go in any
harder than that whereas biden of course
stands to make a lot of money he's
trying to rescue his presidency former
vice presidency from um you know the the
jaws of hell yeah so now he thinks all
right i'll have a meeting and we'll open
up the oil and maybe gas prices will get
lower how about doing it here oh you
can't do that because then you have the
environmentalist lobby here who is just
as illogical who will be mad at you none
of this by the way none of this is
looking out for your best interest this
is why i have a problem with people
saying oh i'm fiscally conservative but
i'm socially liberal look at the
consistency here look at the through
line none of this has your best economic
interests at heart we all know that
everyone agrees on that right now but
none of this has your best social
interests at heart either
they don't want you to have the right to
make your own parenting decisions who do
you mean by they the left well they're
gonna be left versus right because only
one side believes in puberty blockers
and transition surgery for kids how
about that that's why there's left and
right
well he also shows that when he's
running for president he'll say anything
i'm gonna make them a pariah until you
get into office and realize the only way
to make them a pariah is to not be
dependent on them
and the first thing that you did was say
i am going to make it to where we don't
have our own oil i don't we don't have
our energy we don't have the ability to
do anything russia you can do the thing
that you were wanting to do but we can't
do ours and he's come out and said that
over and over and over and over that he
wants to get rid of oil he hates oil
companies they're trying to blame
inflation by the way on price gouging
gas prices are over five dollars a
gallon in this country because oil
companies are gouging you not because i
shut everything down not because i've
said we don't need to do our own just to
be clear before people try and factor
just say well actually we're uh tapping
into more reserves now then okay yeah
sure i understand what you're talking
about right now but it doesn't actually
compare to what leases would have been
made available and by the way it's an
incredibly speculative market people say
that the president doesn't control gas
prices i understand that's more
complicated than that but when you are
dealing with a market that is highly
speculative
the rhetoric of someone saying we are
going to shut down oil and gas the
rhetoric of someone saying hey i am
anti-oil you watch i'm going to end
fossil fuel companies the rhetoric of
someone saying we need to transition to
technology green technology that isn't
quite there yet right and then not to
mention putting a moratorium on new
drilling guess what you have the
marketplace pulled back they say oh we
better prepare for lean times hey just
so you understand it you guys been
preparing for lean times i know a lot of
americans don't save but if you're
watching you're likely somewhat fiscally
responsible are you planning on there to
be some kind of economic downturn if you
plan for that do you spend more if
you're a business owner do you expand
more during that time
or do you tighten down that's what's
happened with the oil you could change
the price of gas
tomorrow with a few key statements and
maybe a fraction of the executive orders
that he signed going the other direction
you absolutely could it's not the only
reason but it's a huge contributing
factor you open up completely you say we
are going to use every single possible
resource that we can so that if
something like russia invading ukraine
who could have predicted that
happens we won't be dependent on opec we
won't be dependent on russian oil we
will be dependent on our own energy and
therefore because we use the most of it
the rest of the world will pay lower
prices opec will have less power that's
how you do it you don't sit there and
wait for the crisis and that's what he's
done well of course that's what they've
always done he's also induced the crisis
yeah that's true yeah well if you wanted
to see the difference mail something to
oklahoma and then mail something to
saudi arabia tell me what's more
expensive yeah it's that simple it's way
cheaper for the us to drill here but it
had to be a problem it had to be the
environment well all these other
countries don't they do not care about
the environment that's the problem with
the entire political system it is it's
all bs and if you do anything to try to
make any kind of change we saw what
happened right
where's greta thunderberg in saudi
arabia and china ah of course
they wouldn't put up with her very long
they don't suffer fools oh greta thank
you thank you very much come in here
come here and lock the door ain't she
gone forever
she's a wiggler why should i wear a mask
yeah okay i mean you know a saudi arabia
mask oh no covered bullet yes
oh
we shot it whoops
all right now let's move on to this is
another thing's a story coming from
across the pond
uh oh hey by the way if you're watching
right now hit the like button yeah right
smash that like button if you're
watching on youtube or hit the share
button uh that's what uh
that's what they like with the
algorithms and i should tell you too as
well um if you don't see us here we're
obviously gone in july we're also
working on some other behind the scenes
productions that i can't discuss right
now so when we're gone we're not really
gone um you can watch us on rumble or
you can watch us on mug club today we
have an additional full hour of show
monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern we will tell you when we're not
here july if you miss us we're probably
not here every other day just tune in
monday thursday at 10. okay here's in
the bbc uh this transgender paramedic um
just uh and the name is steve meach
steph steph i know
he used to be
well if you can spell stephen with a ph
yeah well they took off she took off the
en yeah no she yes she
i'm not gonna get the pronouns right
anyways i'm not trying to do it wrong
because i don't know how to do it right
he receives physical and verbal abuse he
she says from uh patience because he's a
transgender woman and this was an
article can you believe that they're
paramedic i just and by the way this
isn't even keep in mind this isn't even
denying someone who's transgender goods
or services it's simply saying like i
don't want your goods or services
yeah also
emts tend to get messed with pretty bad
unfortunately yes yeah across the board
yes
and by the way i wouldn't blame them if
certain areas of town they were like
i don't have the hazmat suit ready right
it depends on how much effort steph puts
into it right if steph shows up with
like eyeliner and some lipstick and
looks like oh was it not in the overlay
the picture of steph i didn't see oh uh
well it's not good
yeah i mean you wouldn't look at it and
go you probably just think it was gerard
d pardue
[Laughter]
in lipstick yeah you're just coming to
you're like am i in bogus what the hell
is this what i'm in the film
oh oh yeah that's sir
right there
i can't believe anybody else remembered
bogus oh of course it's terrible oh it's
awful now uh this is a story and of
course this is uh again outrage currency
um we were curious and of course we've
been developing our own investigative uh
news arm here at loudest crowder so we
sent
our team out to east essex to uh sussex
east
stevex to learn more
[Applause]
[Music]
it's laying on location with street
beats and today we're in the tough
streets of some poor english town with a
local folk hero the transgender
paramedic hi could you please introduce
yourself oh i'm the transgender
paramedic and uh what's your name
my name used to be tyler but now it's
terry tyler to terry how about that now
i'm sure it's a little tough in today's
world with all the right-wing media
channels and such how does it feel to be
a transgender paramedic oh well it's
very freeing except that
oh my god oh my gosh can you
no are you getting this it's live it's
live what's wrong this man has clearly
lacerated his arms please help him be in
gender paramedics
what are you i'm a transgender paramedic
oh please lay down i come to help oh
alright alright the transgender
paramedic is going to perform
all right all right
right now okay what seems to be the
problem okay i was trying i was trying
to climb the tree there and then i sit
and i cut off with my arm oh what does
your brain say well it's standard
procedure to then go and cut your pants
no i must cut your pants how are you
feeling i must cut your pants off it's
my arm completely all right it's not
it's not anywhere it's my arm it looks
like he needs mouth-to-mouth so i'm
going to perform mouth-to-mouth on him
now okay that is oh my god cut it
[Applause]
[Music]
i get i understand that you know we like
to deal in stereotypes here but why did
we assume that all englishmen look like
gomez adams as a busboy i could only
find a vest
also uh that sketch was four minutes
longer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it wasn't a sketch
i didn't know you were taping that now
here um this is another topic that i
really want to talk about and let me
just i'm curious as to what you think
i'd love for you to comment below the
more i think about it the more i
passionately defend the idea of teachers
being able to carry firearms teachers
who are qualified teachers who want to
yeah i don't believe in forcing any
teachers to carry firearms
but i thought about it so yeah it seems
pretty reasonable now i think it's
actually the only
reasonable first step at this point when
people say oh well you think they're
gonna be more effective than the cops
how many more stories do you need of
people who aren't cops being more
effective than the cops right
you know what's more effective than the
cops being there yeah i was about to say
they they would just at least be there
before the police most of the time right
and so in ohio now um governor uh their
governor mike is it is it deween dewine
de wine i thought it was dewine but
someone corrected me said it's dwayne i
was like
that's bad that's not what it is but
someone corrected me and i always assume
that other people are right d1 so uh
signed a bill um
that does make it a lot easier for their
teachers and staff to carry guns okay so
let me get through um what's changed
okay so back then ohio teachers
they were allowed to carry guns yeah
right they're allowed to carry guns uh
even uh if you go let's just say let's
take it 2021 to now okay because there
are little subtle changes that occur in
legislation all the time so that's kind
of a b test we'll give you they were
allowed to carry firearms that's true
but
and this is where you have it's not do
you have laws it's are the laws applied
equally are the laws applied reasonably
yeah so teachers sure could carry
firearms but they had to undergo the
same
minimum training that it takes to be a
police officer here's from the ohio
supreme court ruling it was no public or
private educational institution shall
employ a person in which such person
goes armed while on duty who has not
received a certificate of having
satisfactorily completed an approved
basic peace officer training program
unless the person has completed 20 years
of active duty so what does that mean
that means you could have been a cop for
20 years and then decided you know what
i want to teach
right as your pension kicks in yeah
right seems right uh or 700 hours of
instruction
unbelievable
now who doesn't have that right well
they have some only work 2 000 hours a
year if you're employed full-time right
okay so just do the math three months
it's basically it's basically half half
of your annual
full-time work the whole time five days
a week now i know that it's skewed a
little bit because you know teachers
sorry the real heroes we have three
months off so
think about that 700 hours you have the
left going well don't you need some
training okay and they say well you
should have 700 hours that's not
reasonable and then they try and paint
my point of view your point of view
right here's their claim now that
they're making the claim that they just
made this morning on cnn and i didn't
have time to read the bill in full so i
was listening to cnn and right away my
bs meter went up and i'll give you the
truth right after they say that this law
does not set a new minimum which used to
be 700 hours of range training for
teachers this was this morning on cnn
let's start with the training time what
is your issue with the training time
reduction i'm handsome
well 24 hours maximum training on this
bill um and what uh it doesn't set a
minimum
so it could be as little as four hours
of training that we're seeing in this
bill
and it doesn't talk about how long you
spend at the range what is the minimum
amount of time
that say a teacher
who might be armed could end up spending
at the range to get their qualification
for this as you see it
yeah i mean it does really say in the
bill i mean what it talks about is four
hours of training in scenario based
incidents um and that's it hey by the
way you people below here uh
can you send this to snopes can you send
this to politifact can you send this to
wapo because i'm about to hit you with
the truth here okay i don't know why
they can't be bothered all references
available at loudofcrutter.com the bill
is there it says in the bill
the approved training programs must
include 20 hours for handguns five more
hours for each additional firearm
so you know when they say donald trump
said he was the greatest president in
the world and like fact check uh mostly
false this is the bill doesn't say that
there's a any kind of a minimum it's
right there yeah well it's in the bill
but also did you listen to what he said
he's like you know 20 hours down to as
little as four but there's no minimum
well then where did the four come from
as little as four says that's the
minimum right you said it in a follow-up
question i just see the number four well
is that the minimum man it doesn't look
like to be a minimum is there a lower
number well four think about this the
guest didn't read the bill the host
didn't read the bill none of the
producers read the bill the booker
didn't read the bill and apparently the
fact checkers looking out for you and
the ones who youtube and facebook and
twitter use to label misinformation
haven't read the godforsaken bill
i'm not making this up
go check the reference i have a link
right to the bill 20 hours for handguns
five more hours for each additional
firearm just to be clear i don't know it
doesn't say in the bill by the way in
that segment you know what else they
didn't include they didn't tell you that
it required 700 hours before that
because basically before that
you couldn't carry a firearm as a
teacher now you can
this is where we should find common
ground right when people say well you
should have to have some kind of
training first off you shouldn't have to
have training to carry a firearm
yourself to have a firearm yourself to
own a firearm i know people don't like
that but the fact that you have the
right to keep and bear arms it doesn't
say after a minimum course but i do
understand that with teachers in those
scenarios
i understand that it's a different
situation contextually but when they say
there should be some kind of training
20 hours
plus five not 700.
where's your middle ground here
isn't that middle ground in other words
it already requires it and they want to
act as though this is the wild west in
public schools yeah i think she's had
700 hours of chin sculpting yep because
that should be bigger and you can kind
of tell it's been pulled in it's
referred to as cool sculpting it cools
gold i found out about that because one
of our lovely fans told me i need to get
it yeah i found out because i was
looking into it myself
after the fan told you no nobody told me
but i agree well we got a couple's
discount yeah we kind of went together
and we're like hey yep have you seen the
new toy story and after that we're going
to go see
christina we're going to make a night of
it okay so
even the governor of ohio he said what
this bigger this time
he said what this legislature has done
i've done by signing it is giving
schools an option based on their
particular circumstances to make the
best decision they can with the best
information that they have that's all
any decision maker
can do now again think about it we're
talking about this law here in ohio i'm
very glad i would like to see more and
again the left says well you can't just
have it without some kind of uh some
kind of prerequisites
they have it
so this is the issue when someone says
not enough not enough not enough okay
you give me the number
give me the number hey comment below i
know that i know that a lot you watching
right now you may be
a liberal a classical liberal not
everyone who watches or listens to the
show on audio is conservative you may be
what's the minimum 20 hours not enough
plus five 20 plus five for additional
guns not enough what does it need to be
30
does it need to be 40. and if you do
that if you if you claim that number
where's the substantiation that there's
a big difference in the number of
someone safely operating a firearm
between 20 hours and 30 hours
or 30 hours and 40 hours or 40 hours and
700 give or take
a hundred
give me the number there is now a number
on the table we now have two numbers on
the table 700
twenty plus five
we should allow the american public we
should allow them to make a decision we
need to represent them honestly what
options are on the table an option is
now on the table in ohio it's a petri
dish we'll see what happens
you need to present one the left never
has to give me a number is if it's if 20
is so offensive that you lie about it
and say there is no minimum on cnn the
most trusted name in news said james
earl jones then give me a number
they won't do it but there's also an
alarming trend because this ruling is
not saying that every school district
has to allow this this is basically what
he said in his quote is i gave them the
option to do that in cleveland they
actually said and by the way cleveland i
wouldn't lead the way on this you guys
suck for public schools they said we're
not going to allow any of our teachers
to carry any firearms can you imagine
like play this scenario out and god
forbid if this happens i hope it doesn't
some cities say yes they arm their
teachers they never experience an issue
or if they experience an issue they get
they're able to take care of it and
protect their children other cities say
no
we're never going to allow somebody to
be armed on our campus who is not a
police officer and a situation happens
and you can't you can't get that back do
you think uvalde would have loved to
have had teachers on campus with guns
during that of course they would yeah
columbine and parkland would have loved
that as well and newtown they would have
loved to have that kind of an option for
protection why is it that people are
against freedom the roe v wade argument
is that i don't want states making laws
this argument i don't want cities to
have that ability
it's two things you have states rights
and then states can also create
municipal rights right the idea is of it
to be decentralized that's important a
lot of people don't understand that but
then you also get to the point these
people claim that teachers are the true
heroes and obviously the police are evil
defund the police by the way what you
think that teachers with guns are going
to be as capable as the police we've
been do you think the true heroes let's
change that phrase do you think the true
heroes are going to be as capable as the
evil racist police force we've been
vilifying for years well i don't know
hold on a second i don't think that
either of those characterizations are
true it's a generalization that i don't
agree with on either side but
maybe
the same teachers who more effectively
evacuated students and protected them at
uvalde
would have been more effective than the
police who did nothing
then the police there who and it's not
because all of these policemen are bad
people are cowards it's because i had a
chief who said do nothing
do nothing they heard students getting
massacred and did nothing and there were
teachers there who were not allowed to
have firearms who were evacuating and
bringing other children to safety oh and
by the way was an off-duty patrol agent
border patrol agent who came in with a
gun that he borrowed from a barber who
stopped the shooter so yeah yeah i tend
to think that
maybe some teachers could be more offen
uh could be more effective than some
police officers but you know that's just
me looking at statistics and the actual
situations that we've just faced which
are the catalysts for these laws so uh
something else by the way thank you ohio
for moving in the right direction and
congratulations to the 155 we have 155
000 people just in the state of ohio oh
nice of us who who watch right now if
you're watching or listening yeah bunch
of thugs fans or at least i should say
155 000 screens screens just in ohio so
i don't know how many people are
watching there'll be bots but yeah
you know does it hurt to try why don't
we just do that because i know a lot of
teachers and i know teachers that are
willing to carry right so it's like why
don't we just try
yeah and that's fair i'm assuming these
teachers are probably people who carry
outside of the classroom yeah yes and
some used to be an enforcement right
yeah so we're not forcing anybody to
carry firearms and by the way i don't
know this shouldn't
conceal carry holders it's the single
most law-abiding demographic that we've
studied they commit fewer crimes than
off-duty police officers
fewer crimes than lawyers okay this is
the most law-abiding demographic that we
have studied
to date
so yeah i think allowing these people to
carry uh in a place where uh obviously
the gun-free zone and people are sitting
ducks i think allowing the people who've
already displayed uh a responsible
proclivity to carrying firearms outside
of there i don't know why their rights
go away bank caring for children yeah by
the way how many hours are most of the
concealed carry i think in the state of
texas what is it like an eight-hour
class right 28 minutes
eight hours produces the most
law-abiding group of gun owners right
that we've seen
and the guy who didn't mind was an
absolute douchebag real oh he was the
worst she's like ah
i wouldn't use that gun if my life
depended on it
really why because i'm going to go into
a two-hour uh completely unrelated side
story here about the time i was at a gas
pump and i was like please just shut up
oh geez just shut up you drive a
six-wheeled truck don't you i do i do i
do yeah i do yeah do you haul stuff no
no i don't know i do not don't work with
my hands ever
look at those have you ever seen them so
babysit go ahead touch them it's like
the duck in the dawn commercial it's
like a lady
you like it and we're gonna go here uh
to mug club by the way hit that like
button hit the share button and uh dave
is going to be this friday in grand
junction colorado just to let you know
we're both there saturday uh in colorado
springs it's sold out but i think i
think there's we put a hold on like 150
or 200 tickets so if you're there you
can walk up because we still want you to
have the opportunity uh and uh of course
lot of cutter.com tour fall tour big
time tickets now on sale you asked for
it we did it we're about to hit the uh
fox news propaganda transitioning
children piece here on mug club and we
wanted to put it on mug club because i
didn't know how angry i would get but i
can guess youtube piss off